nobody is paying attention to these
arcane details unless you are listening
to conservative talk radio if you're
listening to conservative podcasts if
you're
reading in the conservative sort of
media chamber
then you're following these things
closely if you're doing your own
research but for most people that's not
what's happening so you got to show them
that's what this business owner was
doing things are going to get crazier
it's not everyone was waiting for 2021
oh good this is gonna it's all better
now it's all going to be fine
joe biden if he becomes president which
it looks like he will
then he's going to ramp up the lockdowns
he's going to ramp up
the masking our neighbors to the north
america's hat up there in canada
actually had police raiding homes
because six people gathered together to
celebrate
new year's take take a listener
okay
[Music]
older people say what are you doing what
are you doing and the cops still
dragging these family members out
what's amazing too the cops came because
there were there were six people in the
home that was the number
do you know how many cops showed up six
cops
that doubled the risk of covid right
made the risk of transmission so much
worse
i don't think it's about covid i don't
think it's a bad transmission at all
that sort of thing
probably would not happen in america
just yet because americans have
more of a tradition of protecting our
our property
and protecting our families and because
americans through the bill of rights
have the instruments to do so
but you've seen americans roll over
all year long we've rolled over we've
rolled over on our businesses we've
rolled over
on our rights we've rolled over on the
way that we vote
so who knows who knows when that when
that could come here
that is a an unacceptable power grab and
the only way that it's going to stop
is if we stand up and stop it this is
why i say
often when i have to wear the mask
there's certain public places where they
force you to they won't let you get on
an airplane
for instance if you don't wear the mask
then i will
wear it below my nose i will wear it
above my mouth i will
at least protest in some way and more
often than not what i will do
is not wear the mask at all
the argument for the masks early on well
first of all they said
there's asymptomatic spread turns out
that's almost certainly bogus
they said the masks are completely
useless remember fouchy told us that at
the beginning of the pandemic he said
all it does is sort of make you feel
better but it doesn't actually do all
that much to stop the spread of the
virus
which is obviously true but then he
completely reversed his opinion and all
of a sudden we had to
we had to believe him then too even
though he had no credibility anymore
then we were told the masks aren't about
protecting you it's about protecting
other people then we were told in the
future only people who are
sick are going to wear masks which
undercuts the very argument that they
were just making
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts